a remarkable number of teams have
multiple first-round draft choices right
now i've never seen this before
the giants have two
the jets have two the texans have two
the eagles went from three down to two
the saints had one and said we need one
more yeah we got to get one more they
they now have two the packers have two
thanks to their
trade with devonte adams the chiefs took
one of the
draft choices
that the niners gave miami to trade up
in last year's draft they took one of
those first rounders and gave it to the
chiefs
for tyreek hill and as we all know the
ultimate first big
shot fired in the non-playing season of
last year or the uh you know
transaction period of last season was
the
rams flipping a one
for
um and sending jared goff to the lines
multiple ones for matthew stafford
so you've got eight teams
with 16 draft choices a quarter of the
league
is taking up currently
one half of the first round of the nfl
draft in 2022 i've never seen that
before
one of the
people to help us talk about it right
now uh long-time executive in the
national football league certainly with
the eagles as well joe banner back here
on the rich island show how you doing
joe
good great to be on with you i assume
you have a brad pitt character in that
analogy that would be you joe that's you
thank you i'm clooney you're paying
thank you okay that's
at least that's the way we're rolling
right now um why do you think 80 degrees
from that just for the record what do
you think is happening um
where where
people are amassing multiple first-round
picks
in this year's draft or looked from last
year to this year's draft said let's get
in for another what do you think's
happening joe
i think that what's happening is a chunk
of the league is realizing that with a
cap going up 25 million dollars a year
the value of draft picks is less
and one of the great values of draft
picks is you have inexpensive players
for four five six years
depending upon you know where you
drafted them etc
if you can as we've seen the rams do
although some of that is
mischaracterized
if you can
acquire players that are sure things
when you have lots of money and lots of
more money coming in the future
then the first round draft picks a lot
less valuable
so the teams with specific needs or like
an eagles that's positioning themselves
in case needed quarterback for which
they will need less drastics are
cherishing those draft picks
the teams that feel like they're good
enough and close to winning
they're going to have the room as the
cap grows so quickly to fit in
additional players
and the less predictable less certain
quality of the draft fix becomes less
valuable so i think there's a few other
factors but to me that's kind of the
headline explanation we've seen this
happening slowly
as the jumps in the cap became larger it
slowed down a bit last year when we had
the
issues with covet and it affected the
economics of the league so much now
we're looking at two three four years
where 25 million dollar increase in the
cap is probably somewhat conservative
so you don't have to have those
inexpensive draft picks
into the same degree you did not too
long ago when people needed those draft
picks so they could sign the ramseys of
the world
now they don't need to do that because
they're getting a gift
that's equivalent to almost the most
expensive non-quarterback in football is
how much the cap's going up every year
joe banner here on the rich eisen show
long time nfl executive okay what do you
think
uh of the saints eagles trade let's take
it one at a time here what do what do
you think the saints are up to
by striking this deal
you know it's hard to understand i mean
they have been a team that is a little
more short-term thinking than most so
even with some cap challenges that kind
of contradict what i just said you'd
think they'd be
appreciating the value of draft picks
what they really did is just move to
pick forward so a pick that they should
have had in 23 they moved to 22. now you
know i think they paid a steep price for
that but if we really want to simplify
what happened instead having one pick
and 22 and one pick and 23 they say
they're gonna have two picks and 22 and
no picks and 23 in the first round
so you'd think that they were targeting
somebody but i don't know how three
weeks before the draft in the middle of
the first round you'd know enough about
who's going to be there because the
other possibility is they're planning on
using those picks to trade up for
somebody but i'm in the school of not
thinking there's a good enough
quarterback in this draft that that's
warranted so
i'm not sure what the saints are doing i
did not think they did a great job with
this trade even if we just talk about
the negotiation and i want to make this
deal but what's the cheapest price i can
pay and still get it i think they were
overly aggressive so what what what
don't you like what do you think they
how they maybe got had in a way here
well this is what happened i mean the
eagles basically moved back you know or
from 19 to 18
and then they traded the 16th pick what
they got for the 16th pick is a one a
three this year
a one next year and a two the year after
so to me that seems like a huge price to
pay for the 16th pick and the draft and
we've seen teams you know play that pay
that to move from
ten to three or whatever we've seen
teams acquire some superstar players for
that kind of compensation i mean ramsey
and tonsil were two ones
you could argue that one a two and a
three is is almost as much as you're
paying for a tonsil and
ramsey and you're getting the 16th pick
and you're not even sure who's going to
be there
so for me to have paid that much without
uncertainty for a pick at that range in
the draft seems like a
very very good deal for the eagles
for which they should be applauded and
they consistently make strong trades and
for me kind of a question mark on what's
the saints next step or they really give
up a one two and a three just to move a
draft pick from 23 into 22. well what
don't you think i i would think that
there has to be
um
i shouldn't say it's no certainty but
you'd think that there's another move
here that they've already spoken to
somebody maybe top five top ten saying
we want to get up there
and whatever they just coughed up to the
eagles for this first rounder is the
cost of doing business to get where they
wanted to go for the player that they've
already identified
what do you think that's certainly
possible and it would make more sense if
that's the case but
at least from my few phone calls and
nobody in the media is reporting for
example did they call the giants who
have two picks in the top ten
because i'd be surprised if they
couldn't get one of those picks for this
big a package
if i'm sitting at nine and you say to me
you get a one and a two and a three
and you get you still have that top five
pick
and that's all it's gonna cost you get a
one two and a three and you get people
that took over in
giants and i give them credit because
they're not trying to
kind of win the off-season in their
first year
you know why wouldn't they do that so
that's why i said i don't know the value
is there even if that's the strategy
that you'd think they'd go to the teams
with the top ten picks first and say
listen can i just make one move here
and actually
trade my 18 this year and i won next
year i'm trading two ones that's really
what they did and i'm getting back for a
higher pick than 16. that to me that's
the mystery at 16 i don't care who you
are you don't know who's going to be
there
unless you get some real sleep or you're
absolutely positive and then why are you
trading all this to get up if he's a
true sleeper
so it's totally plausible to me that
you're right and
they have two picks now they can move up
if they want to but if they if that's
what they're doing i would have gone to
the teams that have
two picks at least one of which is
higher than that
and maybe they did but the few calls
i've made to people and just watching
the media no one has put anything out
like that so
i'm i'm feeling like they probably
didn't actually do that joe banner here
on the rich eisen show let's get to the
eagles side of things is this
viewed as you know look um somebody
knocked on their door and it was too
good to
not do they already have two others
right they improved on one of them and
they coughed up uh another into next
year is this
could we view this as a hedge on
jalen hurts again
is that a possibility for us to take a
look at it that way do you think i don't
think it's a possibility i think that's
exactly what's happening
i mean i think the eagle's attitude is
listen
the market is not allowing us to
maybe go after what we'd like to find in
the quarterback now and we saw some
positives in jalen
so no harm in giving him another year
let's see how much he can develop where
we're at to be honest i think they're a
little skeptical about that
but what they're trying to do is make
sure
there's maybe nobody in the league that
if we look at the history
all the way back to when we got donovan
mcnabb and look what they did with wentz
and michael vick i mean there's no team
in the league that has demonstrated
their commitment to try to get a
difference-making quarterback than the
eagles
i mean just look at how much they traded
to get up and went let's forget they
ended up getting the evaluation wrong
but it was a real commitment to trying
to get a difference-making quarterback
so i think what the eagles are saying
okay this is kind of no lose we're
getting great value in the trade
if herds turns out to be the guy we've
got all these resources two ones this
year two ones next year plus these other
things
to surround him with even better talent
if he's even better than what we think
he is at the moment
we've got a great plan to go forward if
not
they've positioned themselves at this
early date with as many resources
available to trade up and get one of the
quarterbacks will be in next year's
draft
everybody seems to agree it's a lot
stronger than this year's draft that's
not a very high bar to hit
so i think that's exactly what it is the
eagles are creating an insurance policy
here and frankly one i think they think
they're probably going to need
but if they don't no harm done and if
they do very smart to have anticipated
before it was too late or some of these
other teams had made trades and weren't
still interested in having this kind of
a conversation walk me through the
skepticism on hertz joe walk you know i
think that you're seeing
a quarterback who in a uh run-oriented
offense like what they ran the second
half of last year
uh what we see the ravens doing what we
see
somewhat what the
arizona's doing las vegas um in arizona
sorry it's doing with kylo mari
uh i think he proved he can be very
effective in that scheme i don't think
i've known jeff luery for a long time
worked him for a long time and holly
roseman as well
i think that they'd like to find a
quarterback that can actually carry the
team
and be talked about in the top five
worst case top seven quarterbacks in the
league
i just think as you look at his i mean
to me the keys to the quarterback are
how quick is he processing and how
accurate is he throwing
if you can check both those boxes and
the arm is at least adequate you can win
a lot of games in the nfl i think when
it comes to the processing part and i
want to say this carefully processing is
different than intelligence i've worked
with
people saw quarterbacks that were super
smart people
but they weren't necessarily the
quickest processor on the football field
and i saw people that i didn't think
were that smart and they had incredible
instinct on how to process quickly on
the field so i'm not
making a dissertation here on whether
hertz is smart or not i'm just talking
about the specific
skill at processing quickly
as you're about to get the ball snapped
into your hands i think there was some
concerns there about just how quickly he
processed
and maybe more time will improve that
and i think his accuracy is just okay so
if they're truly looking for a top five
to seven quarterback i personally don't
think they have it in hertz and they're
set up now that if that turns out to be
true they have a chance to get that guy
jalen hurts uh the quarterback of the
eagles for the moment and you know you
just heard uh joe banner walking you
through
everything going on in philadelphia
right here on the rich eisen show look i
i could sit here and say which is the
most important transaction from this
past season and
past march which was off the charts but
the one that we know is going to have
the longest ripple effect in this league
is without a doubt the uh fully
guaranteed deal for desean watson and
i'm wondering
how you see this playing out that
there's going to have to be an owner in
this league that stares at his you know
generationally talented kid quarterback
who he is deeply and madly in love with
and why not because of how good he is
and how um to use the mayok phrase clean
off the field that he is and say to that
person i'm not guaranteeing every single
dollar i'm not putting that much money
in escrow sorry
right i mean that's the way it's going
to go or or
an owner is just going to have to do
this because the haslems just did for
somebody that had 22 civil suits hanging
over his head what do you think joe i
think it'd be really hard to
be the owner that says that
although when we think about the
quarterbacks that are now or within a
year going to get those new contracts we
have some of the owners that if
anybody's going to say it they're going
to say it i mean mike brown
is
i guarantee you're not happy with what
happened and he's a year away from
having to sign a guy that just carried a
team to the super bowl you know san
diego is a year away from needing to
sign justin herbert
not sure what's going on in baltimore
but they presumably like to sign their
quota back at any moment these are mid
revenue to low profit teams
and they bring the league back to a
point where there were legitimate
debates about whether low profit teams
versus high profit teams was affecting
the crit the competitive balance of the
nfl
so i know we're in the weeds a little
bit for the average fan but this is
going to affect you and your team
sooner or later and it will affect a lot
of quarterbacks a lot of contracts
sooner or later and some quarterbacks
right away so
uh you know the somebody some owner is
going to get a lot of pressure to do
that whoever's doing the next deal
because one deal when you're negotiating
you can explain as an outlier an
aberration
you start to see two deals or three
deals a precedent is now established and
you don't have a case to make
so we've got a couple of owners if
anybody's going to take that hard
position
and at least postpone doing the deal
remember they could keep borrow for
three more years and two tags um
it's it's cincinnati is the most likely
team in the whole league to do that
at least in terms of how far he took his
team they just had the quarterback
that's the best of the group i just
mentioned so this is going to affect
everything and you're right not many
owners are sitting with 200 million
dollars they can just put into an escrow
account
and i know that sounds funny to the
public because they're so wealthy but
they're just not structured in a way
that that's a natural thing to do or a
smart thing to do frankly in most
instances
so
what about arizona don't you think that
maybe whatever you know last time you
were on we talked about that and i have
it here still because again his
stationary is so impressive the calamari
stationary that uh eric burkhart sent
out his statement his sort of um you
know uh jerry maguire type manifesto
saying that my guy wants to be your
quarterback he wants to be paid
appropriately don't you think that
whatever um conversations that chime
steve kahn the gm there and michael
bidwell the owner is there that's had
with eric burkhardt um uh uh kyler's rep
representative
whatever framework was working on got
completely changed by the the watson
contract don't you 100
not not even a maybe are probably a
hundred percent
and and as with every one of these guys
that are coming up here soon that are
playing
at uh such a high level everything's
changed now there is a compromise
outcome okay and it's dependent upon the
quarterback really because if you do a
three or four year deal
and what cleveland did is still
problematic but massively less
problematic
what cleveland did that such a problem
for everybody is they went out five
years
made him the top paid guy
skipping roger's contract which is
written in kind of funny way for the
moment when i say that
um
fully guaranteed the whole thing and
he's a guy that has a whole bunch of
offshore problems you didn't even get
the normal
forfeiture of guarantee language that we
get in contracts with even players that
have absolutely no questions whatsoever
about their character
so it was the details of it that made it
so problematic now if kyle murray said
listen i'll i'll find a three-year deal
because i think the cap is going to go
up in three years i'm going to get even
bigger deal that you give me now i think
arizona would feel like they were lucky
and they won and then the amount of
money needed to put in escrow and all
that stuff goes down very dramatically
but i'm certainly if i'm a player i'm
trying to figure out why in the world
should sean watson get anything i didn't
get
and again i'm talking about the top guys
when i said that the boroughs and the
herbert
but that will be the fight i mean
they're sitting there going listen
either you get a partially guaranteed
deal at the right average
or we can give you a
very high average and a fully guaranteed
contract but they'll say it has to be
three years and then maybe they
compromise at four that's the only way
these teams and these owners they have
strong philosophical objections to what
happened that's the only compromise i
can even think of of how do i keep this
guy it's joe barrow i'm not letting him
go
but everything i've done for the last 40
years of my life as an owner of the team
says everything cleveland did is
everything i don't believe in
maybe they go to a shorter term deal as
a compromise to at least get it done and
listen there is an argument from the
player's side
with the way the cap is going to go up
maybe i'm better going back to the
market three years i got some choices if
i want to
go to another team or this isn't the
right place for me and instead of
waiting five years i have to wait three
i'm getting a fully guaranteed contract
and probably the quarterback's gonna
make even more money three years from
now than five years from now it's not a
crazy thing for a player to think of
doing and it will
won't eliminate it will mitigate the
damage that the watson contract did to
the market as a whole so uh joe before i
let you go i guess i'm gonna get greedy
and i will now ask you what you would
which uh march transaction do you think
will affect wins and losses the most um
and and it could be on on either end
adams goes to uh vegas and leaves a hole
atop
the offense um for green bay anything
like that russell wilson tyrek hill i
mean the names were insane
last month jill which one do you think
yes
i mean listen i'm going to put the sean
aside for a moment which i do think is
the most consequential because it's
going to affect so much in the future i
mean my my answer to this question is
russell wilson i do not see the
deterioration
from what i believe was an extremely
high level of performance that some
people seem to feel like they've seen in
the last year or two
i think devon has a lot of other
positives obviously the primary negative
is in a division that's just impossible
you could be a very good team and come
fourth place in that division it
wouldn't even be shocking in fact a very
good team will come in fourth place in
that division so that scares me but i
just think russell is an outstanding
player i think he's actually been held
back by the scheme and the approach
they've taken to the game in seattle and
i think he has the ingredients there in
denver to really make a dramatic
difference if they were in any other
division i would be calling them like
the sleeper team that people know has
some talent but still underestimated and
now they have a top tier quarterback so
i'm going to go with russell wilson joe
banner uh much appreciated
33rdteam.com to read uh joe's musings as
well as on twitter i appreciate you
taking the time here joe always always a
pleasure thanks for watching right back
at you that's joe banner
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here